[Music]
the world record for fastest marathon
stands at 2 hours 2 minutes and 57
seconds that doesn't come close to
what's humanly possible human physiology
expert Mike joiner examine human
thresholds for oxygen uptake and lactic
acid buildup and calculated that the
fastest marathon a human could ever run
is 1 hour 57 minutes and 58 seconds but
reaching this limit will require the
right course on the ideal day with the
perfect runner since 1988 runners have
broken the world record 11 times 7 of
those World Records took place in Berlin
on average runners finish 81 seconds
faster and from Lynne than other races
that's likely because the course is
relatively flat and straight another key
factor is temperature researchers have
found that the fastest runners invest at
thirty eight point nine degrees
Fahrenheit which could explain why over
half of the best marathon time since
2000 run in April or September but it's
not just the course it's also the runner
it turns out the perfect runner will
likely be smaller than average elite
marathon times for men went from two
hours eleven minutes and 49 seconds in
1992 two hours seven minutes and ten
seconds in 2011 at the same time the top
100 male marathoners went from an
average weight of 131 point four pounds
in 1990 to one hundred twenty three
point nine pounds in 2011 and their
average height went from 500 point one
inches in 1990 to five feet six point
nine inches in 2011 this likely has to
do with the runners body heat shorter
smaller runners produce less heat
and dissipated faster so they overheat
less quickly they can run faster for
longer distances
other factors include endurance
confidence and how efficient a runner is
in delivering oxygen to the muscles it's
a lot of pieces that must fit together
perfectly but perhaps one day the right
runner will compete with just the right
track in history will be made